[Music]
what's up wisecrack jared here and today
we're talking about everyone's favorite
president Dwayne Elizondo Mountain Dew
Herbert Camacho when idiocracy was
released in 2006 Fox allegedly tried to
bury it apparently they were worried
that sponsors might be upset that save
this Carl's jr. q.i meeting despite
their efforts idiocracy has become a
cult classic people not only loved the
film for its amazing toilet humor but
for its political prescience idiocracy
is perhaps less known as the story of
unwitting time traveler joe baugher's
trying to get back to 2005 and more as a
cultural artifact that embodies what
some see as society's gradual
degeneration in idiocracy x' america a
pro-wrestler becomes president politics
has devolved into shouting matches - the
notion here people gamble for healthcare
corporations pretend to care about you
welcome to Costco I love you and most
tragic of all everyone's forgotten the
word for tortillas we running out of
french fries and burrito covers yeah
leading up to the 2016 election one of
the film's screenwriters ate hunk Owen
first said the film had become a
documentary Fast Company similarly noted
that president Dwayne Elizondo Mountain
Dew Herbert Camacho's parallels the
Trump are quote undeniable with fully
automated fast-food Switzerland opening
a fellatio cafe and oh my balls being
inoffensive when compared to anything
Logan Hall is done the similarities to
our world seem uncanny
but just how prescient is is idiocracy
as a lens to understand our current
condition missing the mark or did it
really all come true let's find out in
this wisecrack edition on idiocracy deep
or dumb and as always spoilers ahead
but before we get into that I want to
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
raid you might have heard us talk about
raid before it's an awesome hero
collector RPG for iOS and Android it's
totally free to download the graphics
look awesome and the hero design is
top-notch
I mean this dark help has the level of
detail I'd expect from a console game
I've been playing for a couple weeks now
and as far as I can tell there's no
paywall it's got a detailed storyline
giant boss fights PvP battles and
hundreds of champions to collect and
customize and again the detail on these
heroes is darn impressive raid is
blowing up so get in now there's an
upcoming special launch tournament with
prizes you won't want to miss out on
click the link in the description to
download raid to get 50,000 silver
immediately and a free epic champion on
the 7th day of the new player rewards
program see you guys there and now back
to the show
our guys first a quick recap in 2005 Joe
Bowers is chosen for an army experiment
wherein he'll be frozen for a year with
sex worker Rita but the officer
overseeing it gets arrested for some
unscrupulous behavior the base gets
bulldozed and Joe and Rita remain in
stasis for 500 years until a garbage
avalanche unlocks their chambers Joe
discovers the utter degradation of the
world as this once average man
remarkable truly had the most average
person in our entire Armed Forces is now
surrounded by imbeciles in addition to
mountains of trash that nobody knows
what to do with a sports drink called
brando has filled America's water
fountains and irrigation systems leading
to a famine also retail hjs porn balls
aching and farts seem to be the primary
means of entertainment after an IQ test
the world discovers that Joe is the
smartest man alive
so he's appointed Secretary of the
Interior by President Dwayne Elizondo
Mountain Dew Herbert Camacho the first
order of business fixing all these dying
crops when Joe suggests they water the
crops with h2o instead of brawn dough
brawndo stock tanks causing widespread
unrest Joe is sent to rehabilitation
which is just a monster-truck execution
with a few added pieces of flair but he
survives long enough for the world to
see his plan succeed become president
and live happily ever after with Rita
like any good disco
yeah idiocracy is rooted in the real
world in which it was written
having been made during the Bush era
this film is saturated with jabs at
Bush's base of supporters especially the
southern part there's this swipe at
FoxNews language has become a mix of
hillbilly and a few other undesirable
dialects but the English language had
deteriorated into a hybrid of hillbilly
Valley Girl inner-city slang and various
crumbs and their clothing saturated with
sponsors resembles a nascar uniform that
end judges and politicians appealing to
people's sense of folk wisdom invokes
the Texas governor who unlike his
opponents seem like a guy who you could
have a beer with so in the face of a
president who was criticized for getting
C's in college our first question is was
Mike Judge right about
anti-intellectualism
part one anti intellectualism some
people think Mike judges vision of a
world ruled by idiots has already come
true
fake news rules social media and the
u.s. is breaking out in diseases cured a
half century ago so is the problem that
a culture hostile to learning has ruined
the world judge was acutely aware of the
anti intellectualism that existed in the
early aughts
currents that still exists today
idiocracy takes place in a world where
Jo is repeatedly called a for sounding
smart I need help
there's that talk we talked about nobody
can count so that'll be this many
dollars or read away while you keep
trying to read that word the justice
system is a farce based on nonsensical
appeals to common sense prosecutor why
you think you've done it okay number one
your honor just look at him in criminal
justice resembles some combination of a
gladiator fight with a monster truck
rally in other words judge thought a
bunch of illiterate yokels were ruining
democracy and if we weren't careful we'd
end up with this but you could argue
that illiterate yokels ruining democracy
is anything but the truth because today
we don't live in an anti-intellectual
environment but a pseudo intellectual
one here's the difference
anti-intellectualism as many have
personally experienced usually involves
people balking at those who
books appreciate art you get it's the
world of idiocracy but
pseudo-intellectual ism is different
pseudo-intellectual ism involves people
gallivanting around as if they
appreciate scholarship and information
but are largely full of [ __ ] let's go
back to one of my favorite punching bags
flat earthers it's not that flat
earthers are dum-dums who never passed
physics on the contrary if you've dived
deep into the rabbit hole and I'm sad to
say that I have flat earther websites
are full of all the makings of real
arguments they even bought a [ __ ]
$20,000 laser gyroscope to prove the
earth is flat there's evidence
complicated formulas about how gravity
works in their model and appeals to
rational logic to prove once and for all
that the Spheeris are the true idiots
and for every falsehood told it takes so
long to disprove where do you even start
with people rolling out flight plans and
invoking laws of special relativity you
could say the same of anti-vaxxers who
doubt their own MDS and scientific
articles even if they've been debunked
as proof that we the Me's Allah snore
Me's are the true dumbasses and as a
grim warning against what America could
become this line of thinking is
specially popular on the left of the
uneducated ruining everything
just doesn't stack up even Democrats who
accuse people like the Tea Party of
being a bunch of illiterate country
bumpkins I've never seen no toilet
that's good you sure you ain't the
smartest guy in the world have to
contend with the notion that in fact
they were wealthier and more educated
than the general public and the woowoo
New Age Bowl popular among the left is
similarly not because of a lack of
education as we've seen how anti-vaxxers
immense pred in hyper educated places
like Silicon Valley despite the fact
that many claim that idiocracy has come
true our political discourse is much
more lively than ever sure much of it
involves [ __ ] and deranged anger but
it's not the aversion to logic and
information
it's the embracing of a different kind
and arguably a way way worse kind so
while joe may yearn for the days when
people read and there was a time in this
country a long time ago when reading
wasn't just perfect and neither was
it's not quite the solution it's not
that we don't appreciate knowledge we
just don't agree on how to evaluate
knowledge so on anti-intellectualism
mike judges take is certainly funny but
it's maybe not as prophetic as some
would like to think which brings us to a
specific brand of pseudoscience part two
too many babies in idiocracy there's a
specific theory of how the world got to
be so messed up dumb irresponsible
people have tons of dumb irresponsible
kids at rates that vastly exceed that of
your upstanding citizens there's no way
we could have a child now not with the
market the way it is no that just
wouldn't make any sense with no natural
selection the general populace will
continually get dumber until well this
and the number one movie in the country
was called as this very idea was
explored by henry herbert goddard in his
hugely influential book the Calla [ __ ]
family
Goddard's book studied the family of the
pseudonym ously named Deborah kala [ __ ]
and how her family began eration zuv
idiots he traced it back to one
upstanding revolutionary soldier who had
a fling with a tavern girl that resulted
in the spawning of scores of moral
degenerates meanwhile said soldier
martin cala kak went on to marry a nice
Quaker girl and begat a long line of
upstanding citizens
Goddard's chart even resembles the
family tree of idiocracy with the bad
people out numbering the good people
Goddard's work was grounded in the idea
of feeble mindedness he even coined the
term [ __ ] the idea was simple
feeble-mindedness was spreading like a
disease and it needed to be stopped or
else we might get something like this
goblin powder didn't invent a movement
but he certainly popularized it it was
called eugenics Goddard's method was
riddled with errors and inaccuracies
he later renounced his work with the
eugenics movement spread like a wildfire
based on now debunked ideas about
genetics and forced sterilization
program started popping up across
America it even resulted in a Supreme
Court case where the court not only
upheld a sterilization law but commented
to the plaintiff that three generations
of imbeciles are enough so you know the
opposite of this Cleavon is lucky to be
alive
he attempted to jump a jet ski from a
lake into a swimming pool and impaled
his crotch on an iron gate but thanks to
recent advances in stem cell research
and the fine work of doctors Krinsky and
Altschuler Cleavon should regain full
reproductive function Mike judge has
specifically addressed this criticism of
idiocracy that it's Pro eugenics by
saying this to me I thought the opening
made it very clear that whatever side
you take nature and nurture are both
covered in that that guy is clearly not
a good father I mean there's a kid with
a motorcycle in the front yard and no
one is paying attention to this
he's just responsibly knocking up
different women and proud of it it's not
like he's a good upstanding role model
for the kid
so I think it's pretty clear here that
whichever one it is nature or nurture
there's some combination of both I
obviously don't believe in eugenics
despite his qualification on the intro
to the movie dumb people having kids is
not making the world dumber
while idiocracy shows the chart of IQ
scores declining the opposite is true a
Hugh scores have been increasing on
average by three points every year in
other words if Joe actually took an IQ
test in 500 years he'd be dumbest and so
would I and so would you dumbass
smartest guy in the world you're pretty
dumb sometimes
for a more asinine example of our rising
standards consider the white house party
scene you might think that this is a
sign that the White House has
deteriorated so thoroughly as to turn
into a rager but this is exactly what
happened after the first inauguration of
Andrew Jackson after a Mass of 20,000
people descended on the White House to
meet the new president they wreaked
havoc inside until the staff set up bath
tubs full of booze on the White House
lawn to draw people out overall we can
label some of judges critique as the
common refrain of
deterioration language is getting worse
cinemas getting worse TV is getting
worse and it's the end of the world but
it's an old complaint and one that's
never really true Theodor Adorno
complained that jazz was the death of
good music and people will never ever
stop complaining about how the youths
are ruining language in the preface to
his English dictionary in 1780 Thomas
Sheridan complained that nobody gave -
it's about how to pronounce words
properly anymore
and similar complaints can be found
throughout recorded history but let's
not forget that it's the so called a
deterioration of language that makes new
languages otherwise half of Europe would
still be speaking Latin or proto German
not French English Spanish or Italian
still we can all hope that Fuddruckers
rebrands as but endures so on the
question of will the world get dumb we
got to say judges answer is kind of dumb
but let's talk about what idiocracy
might have gotten right part 3 corporate
culture and spectacle one of judges
observations that is certainly not
disappearing anytime soon is the
infiltration of corporate culture into
our personal lives
there's the affer mentioned welcome to
Costco which only seems a few degrees
separate from the corporate Twitter
accounts who act like real people who
are prone to depression characters are
named after brands like frito
dr. Lexus Formica Velveeta Hormel and
president Dwayne Elizondo
Mountain Dew Herbert Camacho and one
must only imagine that beef supreme is
some unreleased Taco Bell masterpiece
speaking of Taco Bell they've possibly
merged with AOL and the US government or
at least teamed up to provide
long-distance phone service Carl's jr.
is able to take custody of children you
are an unfit mother your children will
be placed in the custody of Carl's jr.
and the house of representing is
sponsored by American Express now
whether that's a credit-card company or
an HJ provider we'll never know
Mike judge certainly wasn't inventing
this out of thin air while corporate
lobbying goes back to at least the 18th
century the election of a vice president
who was formerly CEO of an oil company
brought new fears of corporate influence
on American politics which makes scenes
like this so perfect I'm a Secretary of
State walk to bark Carl's jr. why do you
keep saying that cuz they pay me every
time I do this didn't start or end with
Dick Cheney Obama's list of economic
advisors read like a who's who of
Goldman Sachs alumni and more famously
everyone's mad at this dude from Verizon
for trying to kill net neutrality as
chair of the FCC idiocracy imagines a
sports drink company buying the FDA and
FCC which allows them to push forward
their agenda of watering crops with
Brando this isn't so much prophecy as it
is on the nose hyperbole about how
politics already works and with the rise
of branded content we're an airline
company might pay BuzzFeed to write an
article about 10 must-see travel
destinations this distinction between
public discourse and private companies
is increasingly diminishing and nobody
can save it this ever decreasing gap
seems to have led to another problem the
spectacle ization of politics
corporations media and governments have
created a grotesque Frankenstein where
only sex and violence can capture the
public imagination and we probably don't
need to beat a dead horse to tell you
that this this and this I don't know the
Secretary of the Interior even is it's
basically true so is idiocracy deep or
dumb well it's definitely a hilarious
snapshot of early 2000s paranoia about
where the world is headed but it's
paranoia that's slightly misdirected at
least some of the time regardless it
beautifully functions as a cautionary
tale of what happens when people cede
their ability to think critically and
just become mindless consumers but
Brando's got what plants crave it's got
electrolytes and for that we will always
love it thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]